I turn to my right and I find here a man
who's played ten years in the National
Football League now an analyst for Fox
Sports in a Super Bowl champion with the
Green Bay Packers great to see you Greg
Jennings to see always good to see it's
been a while it's been a while it's been
a minute as they say um and you were
talking about your bracket that you've
got a couple you you're a to bracket
yeah I got I get well here's why so I
got a hopeful bracket from the state of
Michigan went to Western Michigan I'm a
Bronco but I know your Kalamazoo got
Wolverine that heart like I see now this
is where things I've had this
conversation with you and it kind of it
tears me apart I've been here because
you were offered by Michigan and then
not offered is that why you did not go
play exactly what what took place I
committed verbally and like three weeks
before signing day they pulled out they
thought I was playing basketball they
use whatever excuse they would use
whatever um and if this was a Lloyd Carr
this is Roy Carr ear so we're getting
ready to play I'm at Western Michigan
we're getting ready to play Michigan and
Lloyd cars doing this interview he's
saying you know I'm sure they got some
players on their team that feels like
they should be here or they deserve the
right or had an opportunity and I'm
thinking you're tight you talking to me
like yet nobody else on this team just
had that opportunity like you're talking
to me and yeah man I went up there and I
had like three or four catches for like
60 yards on Marlins actually remember
Marlin of course he had a career with
the Colts for a while he had a nice pro
career my career in Green Bay
Lloyd Charles Woodson yeah
told me to stay down we were playing
Detroit in Detroit and he's like gee
stay down here real quick Lloyd Carr
comes around the corner and he
apologizes for and I'm like it all
worked out it's all good I'm where I
need to be now I mean it all worked out
but he yeah he came up to you and he
said it was it was it was it was all
good I was hard bro I mean like tears
that's all I wanted to do is go to
Michigan sister was there
yeah well it all did work at all did
workout and you played with the goat in
Woodsen I mean he it's him and Brady on
either side of also player right right I
mean and he's gonna be first ballot
hall-of-famer
without question what do you think's
going through Jordy Nelson's mine right
now Greg a lot a lot ways into moving on
if he decides to move on there's a lot
of value valuable things that he had and
he still has and hold on to in hoe deer
in Green Bay and a lot of variables that
come into play to move on to a situation
where you're with a young a quarterback
in a young receiving room new head coach
kind of not starting over but getting a
fresh new look with the Raiders if you
will if it works out but I'd me
personally like and I can say this
because I wore a different uniform I
can't see Jordy in another uniform like
it's it's hard for me to see him in
another uniform it's a lot of reason
it's unbelievable that you who would
definitely know firsthand that it's a
business okay you know it is a business
dealt with it okay
that you still can say something like
that and it's interesting I'm I'm
imagining I do recall you went to the
Vikings cuz you wanted to pull a Favre
right I mean you wanted to go and just
play against Green Bay twice a year and
be really didn't have anything to do for
me it was it was it was a contractual
deal Green Bay wasn't willing to pay me
and you know you hear all this hometown
discount all of that yeah that's great
but the discount that they were asking
for it was beyond the discount it was an
insult to the word discount it really
was and it was almost as if they hadn't
they had taken for granted what I had
done and for me I had to bet on myself
and I went to Minnesota which was a
struggle for me because I knew I knew
what I was getting myself into from a
quarterbacking situation but I wanted to
make it work and it was a better
situation for my fan
and I and it's I mean we're still there
we're still there are I'm still in
Minneapolis with my family kids are all
in school my wife has our business and I
mean we enjoy where we are in life but
it's a lot of things come into play when
you're making a decision to move on or
to stay I honestly think Jordy still is
weighing in the back of his mind of
coming back to Green Bay somehow someway
somehow someway that that that let's
figure out the monetary aspect of it I
mean I think he would love to end his
career in Green Bay I didn't want to
leave nobody look at Drew Brees jewel
breeze didn't test free agency not
because he knew he could get more money
or he was afraid that they would he
would be offered so much he didn't test
free agency because of what we saw with
Zack strife his retirement speech
talking about how much jus brady's meant
to him in his Drive and his passion and
why he wanted to play the game at the
level that he was able to play for so
many years it's more than just football
and I think that's what fans Outsiders
don't quite put into consideration it's
not just about football Jordy has spent
his entire life in football life in
Green Bay his family the ties of
relationships that he's developed not
only with the players but with those
around surrounding the organization his
philanthropic work he's got young kids
two young kids I mean it it's a lot that
you have to weigh the bear is a nice
place to live though too
so I'm a guy see you hopefully maybe
this maybe that's what he's gonna figure
out but I know exactly what you're
saying and you know and it's it's never
easy it is never easy it's never you
know and Joe Thomas is going through
something right now to try and figure it
out and he said his body told him that
he's not ready to play anymore just as
the Browns are starting to make all
these moves which was which was really
interesting very interesting because he
was at one point lobbying for Kirk
Cousins yeah and then it's like no
though I mean it happened it does Greg
Jennings here on the Rich Eisen show and
cousins he's in Minnesota right now he
arrived today how do you think that is
gonna work out Greg I really like the
situation
I talked to Kurt Kurt when he was in
Minneapolis for the Super Bowl and I
told him this would be a great place for
him to end up I think Mike Zimmer his
personality Kurt cousins personalities
would match mesh really well the one
thing that he has the advantage that he
has over a case keenum is his arm
strength and for those who don't play
receiver or those who aren't offensive
coordinator or plan defense you can take
arm strength for granted it's it is
everything you you allow your receiver
to get the ball in their hands a little
quicker they have more opportunity for a
run after the catch and with those
weapons that he is walking into the atom
feelings the Stefon Diggs the Kyle
Rudolph's the the young running backs
like he has a lot to work with offensive
line was sure it up and you have a
safety net in your defense that you know
they're gonna get you the ball back
they're not gonna put up a lot of points
it's a it's the perfect storm for Kurt
cousins yeah and then guaranteeing all
that money that was the end of that I
think I love it absolutely love it he
has changed this is when I saw even the
discussion the possibility of it even
happening I was excited because there
was at least talk of it in in this
league and it's not for everybody
everybody's not gonna get guaranteed
money everybody's not gonna do it
because as a general manager as an owner
you have to be willing to invest in not
just who they are as a football player
but who they are when when they walk out
of that building and can you trust that
Kurt cousins you can trust that and he
he put he played himself in a situation
and he was the best available so I love
what he's been able to do he hopefully
others will follow I'm sure others will
try to follow me will they will they
continue to knock down
door you sound like do you receive as
she's Doug Baldwin tweeted out exactly
yeah in less than 240 characters what
you just said that hopefully that this
is not the last that this will be the
norm Greg Jennings is here I want to
take a break because the next person who
is gonna probably ask for that is Aaron
Rodgers yeah and then there's levy on
Bell what's going on there and I just
want to ask you what you thought of all
the free agent moves that we've just
seen absolutely ok we are here with
Western Michigan Western Michigan
Kalamazoo's native son right you wanna
race yeah Warner a fantastic so we got
to also ask you what your favorite
cereal is that's Greg Jennings here on
the Rich Eisen show from Fox Sports back
in a moment
[Music]
all right Greg Jennings here Jennings
picked Oklahoma did you pick Oklahoma I
did you know I I almost did
just because any time a team is told you
can't you shouldn't
oh yeah that's a powerful salutely
that's powerful you're playing with all
of that in the back of your mind and it
it it it pushes you to do a little bit
more than what you possibly would have
done if McCarthy do that for the Super
Bowl
because here's the Steelers they just
won blah blah blah like Ben and all that
Nick he didn't what he did do was was do
a great job of just making it a game
it's a football game he didn't tell it
he said the Super Bowl is for everyone
else this is a football game we know who
these guys are you guys have played
these guys you guys have beaten these
guys this is the Green Bay Packers
versus the Pittsburgh Steelers in
another football game and when he broke
it down like that and he everyone took
out the elements of distractions of
Super Bowl write it he was a hundred
percent right we didn't care about who
they were last year the year before what
they had done we knew who we were
playing wait a minute now I'm
remembering it wasn't McCarthy who
pulled that card it was Woodson with
Obama Woodson did that because Obama
Obama's pick the Bears in the
championship game yeah let's go to his
house now yeah absolutely was not one
who taught spoke a lot when Woodson
speaks everyone listen and so for him to
get up he had not done that all year
it's it was like okay yes okay whatever
you say I mean when he said no egos and
I mean we all everyone can say it but we
truly eliminated all egos
every ego was thrown out the door off
the window that's what that's what made
that team so special and you want it all
in the snow STEMI what is it was a kind
of a weird week it was a really
snow storm a huge snowstorm pretty
normal for all I know for a little bit
more with Greg Jennings and AJ voyage
coming up what a big sequence that was
incredible in Pittsburgh as Rhode Island
just hit back-to-back threes to take a
five point lead over Oklahoma we're all
excited here because the three of us
Jennings here for another segment we all
chose Rhode Island in the first round of
our our competition where the loser
amongst the three of us must wear clown
makeup for all three hours on the
Tuesday after the championship game
edition of the rich Johnson show Chris
Brockman over there is three for three
in the first three years of doing this
competition
nobody knows every year he does yes and
if any of my children my nine-year-old
son my seven-year-old son or
four-year-old daughter who chose
brackets for the very first time okay
she chose Duke to win it all because she
loved the dog Duke from secret life of
pets if we lose to any of them we all
three of us mayor must wear a clown
makeup for that Tuesday show and all
three of my children shows Oklahoma this
game an upset I love it and you chose
Oklahoma I did there's a lot on the line
okay so do you think Aaron Rodgers is
telling the Packers I want to I want
fully guaranteed I want fully guaranteed
because Kirk is he should he should look
in this league the quarterbacks have to
be the ones that make make this
statement make this jump they're the
faces of the franchise's they're the
face of the league and if they're
unwilling to do it it won't be done
repetitively by other players
receivers like again when I say as an
owner and as a general manager you have
to be willing to invest big in the
commodity that you're calling a
commodity the talent and if you have any
type of extras that is against what the
team is trying to get done
ie like an Odell Beckham will he get
paid a lot of money yes will it be fully
guaranteed probably not because of what
we've seen regardless of what the
reality is you know walking out of the
door there's a lot there's other things
that
go on Giorno del Becca but with with
Aaron he's got 13 screws in his uh in
his shoulder yeah but that's that's best
12 that's I mean you you hey look he has
you're not you and I are on the same
page about that's 12 I just know what
and perhaps Marc Murphy and Goodykoontz
would come back at if he said I want
candy I see what what our friend in
Minnesota gets I get mine
they know what they look like without
twelve on the field they do they are
they're not they're non-existent
they're not even competitive like let's
be real here Aaron Rodgers is it's
everything for that organization and for
that team and without him we don't even
we don't even talk about the Green Bay
Packers are quite honestly and that that
sounds harsh but that is the cold hard
reality if Aaron Rodgers is not dressed
in uniform on Sundays or Monday nights
or Thursday night we're not talking
about the Green Bay Packers because the
Minnesota Vikings will run away with
that division the Bears who I think are
making a lot of good moves and additions
who have a really solid offensive line
they're gonna be a lot better than what
people think and alliance in the Lions
by the way it looks like they're about
to sign Frank Gore which by the way
brought that should I be a general
manager the lines I said that I did I
said that when we were when I was in
Indianapolis for the combo it's a good
call they haven't had a thousand yard
rusher a hundred yard rusher and a game
put the Inconvenient Truth back there
and let him run downhill
absolutely and give give Stafford some
balance for a change take a little way
those receivers the king of yak gold and
Tate Marvin Jones come on now that could
be that could be huge
I like that real quick hitters here
living on bail what do you think is
gonna play out there with him
Greg Johnnie's man you know I don't know
I don't know and when it comes to
running backs it's always tough I don't
like the situation he's being put in
because he has to play another year
being tagged now they still could figure
out a deal but when you when you Pro
longer running backs
opportunity to make that money it almost
eliminates his opportunity because now
that's another year of wear and tear and
we know that running backs they just
don't last long in this league almost
there Frank Lester Francoeur he is you
know and I think that's why he's a
little ticked off because it prevents
him from getting maybe that one extra
contract here but I mean he is franchise
tag I think that's the way it's gonna
play out unfortunately for him certainly
since he's you know you see what the
receivers are making I don't know if the
Steelers are gonna set precedents by
paying a running back like like a wide
receiver it's been great having you here
Matt I know you know don't be stranger
down I know I know you I know you're
just up the street in a way but I'd love
to have you here a little bit more often
this was a lot of fun here and then
meanwhile Rhode Island has stretched a
lead over Oklahoma to seven they are on
a flat austere run we got time
so is it is it wrong this is what the
madness is that I'm now rooting against
my children I know that for one shining
moment kids go to sleep on time Joe
weekdays at noon eastern on audience